what up guys welcome to the just hurry
things YouTube channel and welcome to
Pearl daily where I cover this week's
treachery debauchery and craziness
before I start make sure you like the
video let's get this video to 2 000
likes that is the most important metric
that YouTube uses to push out these
streams also guys if you want to support
the channel get yourself a women
shouldn't vote t-shirt today if you want
to be the ultimate alpha male that all
the other men really just look up to and
the women just love get yourself a women
shouldn't vote t-shirt today also guys
our producer for the channel has a
boxing match this weekend in London
England if you guys want a ticket make
sure you DM him on Instagram the link is
going to be in the description okay so
our first story today is now it's
interesting when relationships end so as
you guys may or may not know Sophie
Turner and Joe Jonas are getting a
divorce and the interesting thing is
when these relationships end what
happens is old clips of these people
start to go viral indicating problems in
the relationship that maybe the public
didn't notice before
um so there is a clip right now going
viral of Sophie Turner talking about Joe
Jonas let's bring it up
if you're wearing denim pants at home
like what does that say about you you're
wearing denim during the quarantine at
home when no one can see you and no one
can see what does that say about you as
a person like are you
[Music]
a psychopath yeah and Joe does that Joe
wears denim trousers at home and no one
can see I'm I'm not I'm not wearing
denim trousers you know what's
interesting being in the position I'm in
I feel like I understand what it's like
to be a guy because the same way that
women will degrade men in relationships
they degrade me for just talking
uh Pearl has a channel and a Twitter
and people like what Pearl says and then
Pearl's the bad guy that people think
the stuff I say makes sense okay so
oftentimes what happens what I what I
find is whenever you say something as a
chick all of the women will come out and
just pick you apart oh Pearl I don't
like your fashion your hair your this
you're that you're that you're that and
the list just goes on and on Pearl
you're not this enough hurl uh you swear
and it just becomes a shoot the
messenger which is why I always say
don't shoot the messenger now what I see
women do in relationships very similar
is they just start nitpicking so this
woman is dating a rich handsome
multi-kajillionaire I mean I don't know
how rich he is but Rich enough right a
guy that is Rich famous and good looking
and her big problem let me get this
straight text notes you know her big her
big issue with him is that he
wears jeans during covid
now I'm not saying there were no other
issues in the relationship as you know
you know fame money and Fortune does not
typically equate to a successful
marriage however
um I wanted to point out that men don't
find this funnier cute it is not funny
or cute to make fun of your significant
other in public
I and I already can hear the response
I'm gonna get by pointing this out we
have a real problem in society where we
do not have the level of wives that we
used to that really honor and Revere
their husbands in public